everyone of course um excited
slashed uh freaking out a little bit
that this is the last season
of the walking dead which is i mean this
show has been such a part of the culture
for so long
there's talk that there's going to be a
spin-off
is that right yeah i mean you might be
involved
we'll see it's definitely being talked
about um i think they're
they're they're thinking of a couple
different ideas but i've definitely
had conversations about possibly
continuing the story
of negan um you know we just did the
here's negan story which was sort of the
the prequel how negan became this guy
um and i shot that with my wife which
was so cool
yeah how was that it was awesome it was
really
it we had so much fun i think the
episode turned out really well
but we shot these six episodes we called
the
the covet episodes
i don't need that phone working um we
shot these coaches
maybe that was uh you know what what if
what if they were calling you about
being in the spin-off and you just hung
up on them
yeah well oh well
you idiot we have time we've got still
another yeah okay okay i'll let it go 14
months
we're here for 14 months shooting this
year of the show
wow and then i'm told is this right that
uh you're uh uh your son is going to be
uh one of the walkers is that right he's
going to be a zombie in
they don't say zombie i'm using the
incorrect terminology but
he's going to be he's going to be a
walker in
this final season is that right maybe
that is correct uh uh he actually works
tomorrow
um uh we're very excited
he uh you know one of the other things
he's playing a child walker which uh if
you've watched the show
i think i've had like one or two of them
in 10 years it just doesn't happen so
there's something very special about
that and and now that his wife
his wife his mom has been a walker and
now he gets to be a walker that's so
cool
i like that you're keeping it in the
family you know it's turned into a
little bit of a family business but it
you know one of the things uh about the
covet of it all is
that this year we're only using like say
20 zombies we've hired them full time
for the full year
and so they're a different zombie every
episode maybe more than one zombie
and so gus is uh is also tested
he's tested along with the rest of the
family and so we know that uh
he's good to go uh and yeah
and so it just has worked out really
well so he's 11
and he gets to be on the walking dead in
the final season and it's
super super exciting very bummed i love
the irony that you have to have your son
tested so that he can play someone who's
succumbed to a terrible virus
it's very matter it's crazy yeah yeah
yeah
and we also uh when we did those
episodes
we lived in the show's alexandria set we
actually lived in the rick grimes house
so the whole kind of experience of
of shooting and living during this time
and being associated with the walking
dead
has been very surreal in so many ways i
can imagine